the jurgen experience scarface is
another movie like we were saying that
that that is the introduction for
a lot of people uh they a lot of people
especially outside of miami really just
didn't understand
how crazy things had gotten there and i
have a good friend of mine who's an
ophthalmologist who did his residency
in miami and he would tell me stories
like
he was there in the 80s when all the
crazy [ __ ] was happening
and uh just he was like it was a war
zone you go you would just
everybody was you just everybody coming
in was shot
people were all coked up and all these
overdoses and
well that's i think there's a lot of
sensationalism in that you know
america likes war they like they like to
play up the
the machine guns and all that that was
1930 chicago
time magazine went out of its way to
sensationalize it and i
i was there i saw you know it wasn't
wild that way in the sense of shooting
in the streets would happen rarely but
they happened
people would be gunned down families
were killed
drunk dealers went after families of
each other so yeah there was a lot of
that kind of
internet sign warfare well my friend saw
it because he was in the er
you know so oh i seen it he's doing his
residency there so he was seeing it
i think in any american city there's a
lot of shootings every week
that's true especially right now right
but definitely there was a new element
it was it was the colombian element and
the mariolitos came in
some of them uh cubans who were gangster
element out of cuba
yeah and it got bloody when the the
colombians were not playing around so
there was
a lot of cut throats they used to they
used to
shivatos uh colombian necktie yeah
that's right that's right yeah
and when i was there i heard about a
couple of these guys
uh it was interesting because i was
working both sides of the case i was
trying to get to know the
the crime element is more than so i knew
all the
the lawyers and i went over to bimini
one day
to uh to to get some real information
about them because they couldn't
in the u.s they were scared to talk so i
i located through a defense lawyer a
couple of
some guys in uh in bimini i went down
there and i
met with them and they were talking
because that was bimini was another kind
of world there was
the government was on the take there i
think and they had a lot of speed boats
flying going out of there every night at
the hotel
towards the you know bimini is very
close to miami
and i i was doing coke at that time and
i got
with my wife i mean she was my cover
yeah and i
you know and i hollywood screenwriter he
wants to talk to he did midnight express
they like that you know
they want to know about the business but
then in the middle of this we're all
coked up in the hotel and
you know the way conversation goes and i
drop a name uh
just like that you know a guy i talked
to well he'd been a defense lawyer when
i talked to him
but in the past he'd been a prosecutor
because
prosecutors often flipped to defense
attorneys to make more money
so when i mentioned that name the two of
these three guys got
really uptight and they walked they they
excuse themselves went in the bathroom
when i
i said i [ __ ] up i knew i'd [ __ ] up
and i didn't know what was going to come
out of that bathroom you know if they
thought i was
some kind of cop some kind of
underground informer
because they did they hated that
prosecutor that put them away
and put one of them away so a few
minutes went by there and it was pretty
hairy
yeah but i think i was paranoid
but because they came out and they
didn't have guns in their hands but they
they cut the meeting off and you know i
went back to my room they were staying
in the same hotel
all night i was tense because i you know
i knew they could come and get me it was
their hotel they owned them they owned
the island
right but it was nerve-wracking and i
got out of there first thing in the
morning
the whole point is you say the wrong
word sometimes and you're dead
that's that's the kind of tension i
wanted for this movie i put it into the
scene early in the picture where
mr pacino al gore goes in to make a pick
up make us
a trade and uh he says you know
he senses something's off in this
meeting and you and it becomes that
blood bloodbath with
the dismemberment you remember yes and
yeah
the chainsaw the chainsaw yeah i was
going to bring that scene up yeah there
was a chainsaw
murder at one point yeah there's
something about the way you filmed that
was so
excellent because it was obviously gory
and disgusting but you didn't have to
show it
i didn't direct it i wrote it right
brian de palma did a
great job directing it grand opera no
that's right he did an amazing job
that's right
you when you are talking about someone
who is in that world when when you're
trying to
make a film about a guy who is in that
world who is not a good guy
you your your main guy al pacino
tony montana is a bad guy but he's the
hero
it's a very strange movie well yeah it
is because
he is a hero because he's free in a way
he's a free man that's where people
liked it people white people did not
like that movie when it came out i was
uh
disappointed at first there was the
blacks and the latinos
in the inner cities that went and they
loved it
and also people white people who were
doing some drugs
they went that was the kind of audience
we had we were a bad boy movie
so the movie would didn't do as well as
they'd hoped because it cost a lot of
money
went three months over budget uh it was
a very
tedious shoot i was there the whole time
but
over time the film garnered a reputation
and made money for the uh big money for
them well it's become this iconic
drug war movie i mean it's it's the
movie for gangsters
right it's bold yeah yeah in fact
wherever i go
i'm in the world i mean i pretty much
people oh you wrote scarface you know i
can
i got into salvador i got into the
fascist party that way so i could do
some research research yeah they thought
i had
muy cojones
[Applause]
you